بس يعني مسيره اقل ما يقال عنها انها
حافله بالنجاح حافله بالاعمال الدراميه
السينمائيه حديثنا اكثر عن باسل لكل
المحبينكم معجبينك
انا باسل قاعد جنبكم
جدا
وجدي بعملي هيك هيك بتهموني يعني انه جدي
بعملي زياده عن اللزوم
مؤخرا ااه
خلاص التصوير مسلسلات تمام يعني صار لي
فتره لا باس فيها ما عملت يعني كنت بعيد
عن المسلسلات الطويله بس همم هيثم ان شاء
الله راح بنطلع على الجمهور بمسلسل طويل
شويه يعني ان شاء الله نكون يعني تقال
عليهم مسلسل راح يكون طويل من 90 حلقه بس
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله
معنى باسل باسل ليه ما حتيجي القهوه على
الطريق بس ليش ثمن بالذات يعني هل يعني كل
شيء في الحياه له ثمن
اكيد همم امبارح احنا سكرنا بهذا الموضوع
اكيد كل شيء بالحياه انه تمام
انا شخصيا بشوف انه الحياه ما بتعطيك كل
شيء بتعطيكي من طرف تاخذ من طرف ثاني صح
بالنسبه للثمن هو همم يعني هو يمكن رد
الفعل اللي ممكن يصير بالنسبه
[موسيقى]
لا الحياه للطاقه الجمعيه اللي ممكن تصير
لحتى الواحد دائما يكون في اكشن وفي اكشن
بالنسبه لنا بمسلسل الثمن يعني كله هيدفع
الثمن احنا عندنا هيك شيء بنقول من
المسلسل
[موسيقى]
اسمع
مقطع من الثمن تحديات اللي واجهتموها 90
حلقه صورته في سبعه اشهر اطول مسلسل
يعني هذا النوع من المسلسلات
ههه هذا انا ولا مين
ههه
فكرت يعني الميك اب كان يعني عامل ميك اب
انا من المسلسل الدرجه يعني ايه فالمسلسل
همم طويل همم 90 حلقه مثل ما قلت لكم قبل
شوي